willkommen zur aktuellen sitzung zur
zweiten vorlesung philosophie der
digitalität heute geht es um die frage
nach der kultur der digitalität und
konkret auch um die bedeutung der neuen
medien auch um die kritik der neuen
medien die damit ganz stark
zusammenhängt ich gebe ganz kurz doch
mal einen überblick über die methode der
vorlesung das duft anderen die letzte
vorlesung zu der ich oben rechts sondern
youtube ein link reinmache die verlinkte
ich damit also man kann sich fragen
warum wir uns philosophisch mit der
digitalisierung befassen sollen das ist
nahe liegende einwand und man kann sich
fragen und zwar auch durchaus zu recht
ob die digitalisierung nicht vielmehr
die domäne der informatik ist und dann
auch alles was sich irgendwie
digitalität nennt alles was mit digital
zu tun hat ist das nicht eigentlich die
aufgabe der informatik der
informationswissenschaft der
technik philosophie könnte man auch
sagen warum sollten wir uns da im
weitesten sinne überhaupt mit
philosophisch beschäftigen das ist die
frage die müssen wir aufklären dieser
vorlesung ich würde darauf antworten die
digitalisierung ist schon längst nicht
mehr nur ein triumph für die informatik
seien sie betrifft uns alle
sie hat existenzielle dimension warum
sie transformiert unsere lebenswelt
unseren alltag praktiken zunehmend und
wirft fragen auf über die fragen mit
denen sich die informatik gewöhnlich
beschäftigt weit hinaus reisen und auf
diese über die informatik hinausweisen
fragen auf die wollen wir in den
folgenden vorlesungen und auch in der
heutigen vorlesung genauer eingehen das
phänomen der digitalisierung wollen wir
also ausgenommen philosophischer dhs
technologischer als
erkenntnistheoretische und logische
frage die frage nach dem sein nach der
existenz von digitalen digitalität
gegenständen von ethischer und verlässt
ethischer perspektive betrachten und
auch begrifflich klären hier gibt es
noch ziemlich viele unterhalten und wir
wollen hier mal ein paar kann führungen
auf diesem recht weiten und unbekannten
feld vornehmen wir verbinden ist also
nicht der informationswissenschaft
allein überlassen auch wenn die hier
sicherlich sehr wichtig ist dass es so
die methode und jetzt komme ich auf den
plan der heutigen vorlesung zu sprechen
jetzt werden sie sich wunder zunächst
möchte ich gar nichts über die kultur
der digitalität sagen sondern etwas über
die kultur der elektrizität ich hatte in
den letzten vorlesung ich mache zu
diesem punkt oben rechts und links
gesagt eine philosophie der
elektrifizierung oder der elektrizität
das gibt es gar nicht muss mich ein
bisschen korrigieren es gibt so eine
philosophie die elektrizität ist heute
nicht mehr so sehr in mode aber vor
ungefähr 100
200 jahren war die noch viel
verbreiteter dann muss ich mich also
korrigieren und ihnen was nachliefern
ich beschäftige mich aber jetzt in der
heutigen vorlesung vor allem mit der
kultur der elektrizität oder der
elektrifizierung dann werde ich vor
diesem hintergrund als kontrast auf die
kultur der digitalisierung oder genau
der digitalität eingehen was der
unterschied zwischen
digitalisierung und digitalität ist aber
in der letzten sitzung erklärt und macht
wieder oben an youtube ein link zu
dieser stelle hinein dann komme ich auf
die philosophie der neuen medien zu
sprechen was das überhaupt ist muss aber
auch erklären was überhaupt unter dem
neuen medien zu verstehen ist und hier
bietet es sich an zunächst mal auf die
kritik der neuen medien einzugehen die
wir in der letzten zeit immer häufiger
beobachten können ich möchte die kritik
der neuen medien anhand einiger
prominenter deutschsprachiger titel
behandeln und dann aber auch im
anschluss eine kritik der kritik der
neuen medien formulieren weil ich glaube
dass viele diese kritiken viel zu kurz
greifen und dem phänomen der digitalität
wie es ihren diese vorlesung im zentrum
stehen soll nicht gerecht wird und dann
haben wir wie immer am schluss der nicht
aufgezeigt wird genug gelegenheit für
fragen und diskussion sowohl inhaltlich
als auch formal das ist der plan der
heutige vorlesung und jetzt komme ich
auf die kultur der elektrizität zu
sprechen
es gibt ein neues buch von christa
garcia einem französischen philosophen
der hat ein buch geschrieben und das
heißt das intensive leben eine moderne
obsession ich habe mich jetzt gefragt
was dieses bild genau zeigt es könnte
eine glühbirne sein die für oben
betrachtet wird bin mir aber nicht ganz
sicher irgendwas glühendes elektrisches
energisch ist soviel kann man schon
sagen das passt ja auch gut zum titel
intensives leben so und in diesem buch
da hat er eine interessante these die
sich auf die kultur der elektrizität
bezieht ich zitiere mal von den 1000
möglichen definitionen der moderne
wollen wir uns für die folgende
entscheiden die man als die einfachste
und konkrete ansehen kann die durch
moderne ist die domestikation des
elektrischen stroms
als ich im achtzehnten jahrhundert eine
beispiellose bewegung wie zugleich
wissenschaftlichen und
marktschreierischen forschung und
experimenten schockierenden und
leidenschaftlichen inszenierungen der
möglichen anwendungen dieser neuen
energie elektrizität entwickelte machte
dies die elektrizität zur hauptfigur der
moderne als zauber spur der vernunft
jetzt können wir uns fragen gilt
dasselbe nicht auch für die
digitalisierung ist auch die
digitalisierung etwas was einen zauber
spur der vernunft gleicht eine
hauptfigur der moderne das möchte ich
jetzt erst mal dahingestellt sein lassen
noch ein weiteres zitat bevor die
elektrizität die bescheidene dienerin
der industrialisierung war und die
elektronik und der
informationstechnologien wurde hat sie
sich dem wissensdurstigen europa
zunächst als eine unermessliche hoffnung
dargestellt welche die massen von
staunen erstarren ließ die elektrizität
ermöglicht die nicht nur alles
umzuwandeln sind erlaubt auch alles in
der natur und am menschen im lichte
neuer energie zu verstehen also dieses
umwandeln ja alles umzuwandeln das ist
dieses transformative elektrizität und
ich würde sagen dieses umwandeln de
haben wir auch sehr deutlich sichtbar
bei der digitalisierung mehr noch man
kann es das transformativen man kann das
hier ziemlich analog verstehen zu der
neueren entwicklung der digitalisierung
meine these die aber folgen jetzt
betreten möchte laut diese revolution
diese transformation die wir durch die
digitalisierung erfahren die kraft noch
viel viel tiefgreifender wie tiefer als
es damals oder immer noch die
elektrifizierung tut warum werde ich
versuchen im folgenden zu begründen es
gibt noch ein schönes zitat aus diesem
buch das ist ein zitat von anträgen die
dass dieser autor dass ihr uns hier
präsentiert ich zitiere im letzten
drittel des 18 jahrhunderts ist die
elektrizität er einen
sozialwissenschaftler aufklärung als
eine volkstümliche wissenschaft oder
eine neue physikalische und medizinische
wissenschaft cd zugleich mechanische
chemische militärisch biologisch
psychisch pharmakologisch philosophische
theologische ökonomisch ja sogar
mineralogie und ökonomisch ist
durchdringt alle wissensbereiche und
fasziniert den öffentlichen raum sie
bietet ein neues menschenbild und spielt
die rolle eines sinnlich zu erfassenden
offenbar us all diese bewegungen die
damals die westliche gesellschaft
erschüttern hier sehe ich ganz viele
parallelen zur digitalisierung die
elektrizität die philosophie dass neue
menschenbild hier spielt auch nietzsche
eine rolle wenn wir es auf das phänomen
der digitalisierung betragen oder auch
künstliche intelligenz dann haben wir
hier so was wie post und dran ist muss
ich darf an diese these der singularität
erinnern da mache ich wieder oben rechts
einen link rhein von ray kurzweil in der
letzten sitzung behandelt hatte also
hier sehen wir ganz viele parallelen ist
ist die digitalisierung durch trinkt
ebenso wie die elektrifizierung
eigentlich alle bereiche der lebenswelt
und jetzt müssen wir schauen ob es hier
nur bei einer analogie einer parallele
bleibt oder ob es bei der
digitalisierung sich doch nicht um was
tief ein hinteres handelt als die
elektrizität
so jetzt habe ich kurz die kultur der
elektrifizierung die kultur der
elektrizität dargestellt anhand dieses
sehr lesenswerten buches und wrist onkel
hassia im suhrkamp verlag erschienen und
jetzt möchte ich vor diesem hintergrund
auf die kultur der digitalität zu
sprechen komme ich hatte auch in der
letzten sitzung schon mal kurz dieses
buch vorgestellt kultur der digitalität
heißt es von felix stalder einem zürcher
medienwissenschaftler und ich möchte
noch mal ein paar zitate bringen die
aber anknüpfend an die letzte sitzung
noch etwas erweitern und ergänzen
zunächst sagte er diesem buch seit dem
jahr 2000 verbinden sich viele der bis
zu einer unabhängigen entwicklungen
verstärkt stärken und verändern sich und
bilden nun eine neue kulturelle
konstellation der begriff der
konstellation ist hier besonders wichtig
es geht also um das verhältnis von
verschiedenen entwicklungen die sich der
digitalisierung verdanken er spricht
denn auch von einer kohärenten kultur
der digitalität und nicht von kulturen
der digitalität als er spielt im
singular davon und das ist wenn
besonders wichtig kohärent heißt hier
fügt sich alles zusammen also ein neues
medium greift in das andere neue medium
und bildet in diesem zusammentreffen
eine kulturelle konstellation könnte
auch sagen ein kontext der irgendwie
tragfähig ist und diese tragfähigkeit
diese verschränkung diese vernetzung die
so eine art ja basis oder ebene bietet
die eine gewisse substanz hat das ist
die digitalität also das wäre ja schon
ein schöner ansatz diese frage zu klären
was ist digitalität es ist nicht nur das
nebeneinander von technologien von
technischen entwicklungen die kommen und
gehen ein strom von informationen der
uns mit reist das ist nicht digitalität
digitalität ist wenn sich aus diesen
neuen medien etwas eine gemeinsame
struktur
herauskristallisiert oder anders wenn
darauf etwas in ihm agiert als eine
eigene substanz hat was irgendwie trotz
allen wandels konstant es trotzdem
wandel dem entstehen von 90 bleibt fasst
dieses bleiben im wandel der technischen
entwicklung das ist die digitalität und
hier sieht man auch schön dass die
informationswissenschaft sich nicht an
diesen bleiben denn interessiert zu sein
interessiert sich an diesen neuen
technologien die immer weiter
voranschreiten und die bisherigen
ablösen was dabei zu grunde legt zu ein
roter faden der sich durch alle diese
technologischen entwicklung zieht das
ist die digitalität und hier haben wir
philosophin und philosophen besonderes
was zu sagen natürlich auch die
kulturwissenschaftlerin
kulturwissenschaften und soziologinnen
und soziologen aber eben auch die viele
sitzen er spricht auch von einer enormen
vervielfältigung der kulturellen
möglichkeiten das ist jetzt noch
ziemlich vage gesprochen kulturelle
möglichkeiten und dann kommt er ganz
prominent auf die formen der kultur der
digitalität zu sprechen und das sind 3
die referenz ii ali tät die
gemeinschaftlichkeit und die algorithmen
zieht so viel habe ich in der letzten
sitzung schon kurz gesagt und heute
wollen wir etwas genauer auf diese drei
formen der digitalen kultur eingehen ich
zitiere ihn dazu referenziert also die
nutzung bestehenden kulturellen
materials für die eigene produktion ist
eine zentrale eigenschaft viele
verfahren mit denen sich menschen in
kulturelle prozesse einschalten in
kontext eine nicht zu überblickenden
masse von instabilen und bedeutungs
offenen bezugspunkten werden auswählen
und zusammenführen zu bezahlen akten der
bedeutungs produktion und selbst
konstruktion das ist jetzt eher eine
soziologische analyse würde ich sagen
alles geht darum wie man sich selbst
auch formiert in der kultur der
digitalität und wie man überhaupt zur
bedeutung kommt und hier ist
entscheidend dass wir viel material zur
verfügung haben durch die
digitalisierung und dass wir dieses
material ganz frei und beliebig ganz
flexibel man könnte auch sagen
reibungslos das digitale ist ja nicht
materiell verortet sind es ist ganz frei
verfügbar dass wir durch diese
bezugnahme diese leichtere reibungslose
bezugnahme auf das digitale sowas wie
referenziert erlangen bedeutungs
produktion und selbst konstitution also
das kulturelle die kulturelle praxis der
bezugnahme wird durch das digitale viel
leichter und beschleunigt diesen prozess
weil eben das digitale nicht fühlt sich
vorliegt wie jetzt irgendwie ein stein
und ein stück holz räumlich und zeitlich
die spatzen und digitalen ist alles viel
er vernetzt diese vernetzung des
digitalen die erlaubt natürlich auch
eine viel leichtere und dynamischere
referenziert also bezugs haben um daraus
eigene dinge zu bilden ein weiterer form
der digitalität ist die
gemeinschaftlichkeit man spricht davon
dass es die zweite eigenschaft zeit
diese prozesse kennzeichnet nur über ein
kollektiv getragenen referenzrahmen
können bedeutungen stabilisiert
handlungsoption generiert und ressourcen
zugänglich gemacht werden dabei
entstehen gemeinschaftliche formationen
die selbstbezogene behältern
hervorbringen die unterschiedliche
dimensionen die existenz von
ästhetischen präferenzen bis hin zu
methoden der biologischen reproduktion
und den rutsch menschen römerzeit
modulieren in ihnen wirken dynamiken der
netzwerk macht die freiwilligkeit und
zwang autonomie und fremdbestimmung in
neuer weise konfigurieren entscheidend
ist jetzt dass es eine neue weiß gibt in
der verschiedene bisherige modi der
kultur miteinander in beziehung gebracht
werden nämlich über den kollektiv
getragen
referenzrahmen jetzt kann man sich
fragen was ist in dieser kollektiv
getragenes referenzrahmen den ja auch
gemeinschaftlichkeit mir scheint dass
hier auch vor allem das internet eine
zentrale rolle spielt das internet ist
nicht einfach nur ein
kommunikationsmedium sondern es ist eine
rahmenbedingung innerhalb der es nicht
verschiedene handlungen unter anderem
das ganze ist jetzt hier noch ziemlich
abstrakt formuliert wir wünschen uns
hier noch konkrete beispiele und das
wollen wir auch in dieser vorlesung
versuchen ganz konkrete nachzuvollziehen
es soll nicht nur bei begriffen bleiben
abstrakten begriffen soll wird schauen
wie wirkt sich die kultur der
digitalität wie zeigt sich die
philosophie der digitalität ganz konkret
unserem alltag als dritte eigenschaft
entstand dieser kulturellen landschaft
die algorithmen zitat das heißt sie ist
geprägt durch automatisierte
entscheidungsverfahren die der
informationsüberfluss reduzieren und
formen so dass ich aus den von maschinen
produzierten datenmengen informationen
gewinnen lassen die der menschlichen
wahrnehmung zugänglich sind und zur
grundlagen des regulären und
gemeinschaftlichen handelns werden
können angesichts der von menschen und
maschinen generierten riesigen
datenmengen während wir ohne algorithmen
blind
das ist eine interessante these und mir
scheint hier am ende dieser satz wären
wir ohne algorithmen blind ein bisschen
auf immanuel kant anzuspielen der gesagt
hat anschauen ohne begriffe sind blind
also wir brauchen immer um die riesigen
datenmengen im zeitalter der digitalität
zu verarbeiten um überhaupt verstehen zu
können um was es sich da handelt da
genügt es nicht gemeinschaftlichkeit
zusagen referenz ii ali tät wir sind
überlastet durch die informationsflut
wir brauchen wie er es nennt
automatisierte entscheidungsverfahren
die eine gewisse vor selektion vornehmen
die für uns diese daten handhabbar
machen und für uns schon vorbereiten
also diese künstliche hilfe der
künstlichen intelligenz ist für ihn auch
ein ganz entscheidender faktor für die
kultur der digitalität damit niemand auf
alles übersichtlich bleibt obwohl ja die
datenflut unermesslich ist möchte ich
ein konkretes beispiel gebend hier wäre
zu nehmen eine suchmaschine wie zum
beispiel google oder es gibt
verschiedene andere die dann
automatische vorschläge und bringt wenn
wir mal nach gewissen dingen gesucht
haben so wird uns die suche von
vornherein erleichtert er ist natürlich
eine gefahr damit verbunden die
sogenannte blasenbildung dass wir dann
nur noch in diesem interesse bleiben das
verstärkt sich und gar nicht mehr offen
sind für neue impulse andere interessen
andere themen die zum beispiel mit dem
thema mit dem wir uns jetzt beschäftigen
gerade die den entgegengesetzt sind das
ist eine große gefahr das bedeutet aber
nicht dass damit das phänomen die kultur
der digitalität diskreditiert ist weil
sie gewisse blasenbildungen ermöglicht
das bedeutet gerade nicht ihre
verwerflichkeit sind eben nur dass sie
neue probleme erzeugt die sich aber auch
wiederum im rahmen der digitalität
angehen und lösen lassen das verweist
schon auf eine mögliche medienkritik die
vielleicht auch mit algorithmen zieht
zusammenhängt
ja und jetzt hat er noch hier ein
letztes zitat das ich vorlesen möchte
mit dem ausbau des internets zur
allgegenwärtigen
kommunikations und koordinations
infrastruktur um die jahrtausendwende
begann sich also bisher voneinander
unabhängige kulturelle entwicklungen
über die spezifischen kontext ihrer
entstehung hinaus zu treiben sich
gegenseitig zu beeinflussen zu
verstärken und miteinander zu
verschränken
was einen unverbunden nebeneinander
teilweise marginaler praktiken wurde in
der folge eine neue spezifische
kurzwelle umwelt die vor unseren augen
deutliche gestalt und und mehr und mehr
andere kulturelle konstellationen
anlagen beziehungsweise an den rand
drängen im folgenden stehen die drei
kulturellen form der digitalität im cent
und das heißt jede formalen eigenheiten
die trotz der verwirrenden vielfalt an
bestrebungen konflikt mit widersprüchen
dieser kulturellen umwelt als ganze ihre
spezifische gestalt allein und das sind
jetzt wieder finanziell steht
gemeinschaftlichkeit und algorithmen
zieht weil die meisten kulturellen
prozess unter den bedingungen der
digitalität durch gemeinsame formale
eigenheiten wie diese charakter
inszeniert sind ist es überhaupt
sinnvoll
von der kultur der digitalität im
singular zu sprechen also hier wieder
seine entscheiden these nicht kulturen
der digitalität ist es eine
gewissermaßen corrente kultur.de
digitalität im singular interessant
finde ich jetzt hier seine
charakterisierung des internets als
einem allgegenwärtigen
kommunikations und einer
koordinations infrastruktur dh ist eine
struktur die alles verbindet die
gewissermaßen eine stabilität beinhaltet
und hier reagieren durch dieses
technologische entwicklung ganz neue
formen die stadt er jetzt hier vor allem
kulturwissenschaften wickelt die
natürlich aber auch noch und das soll im
zentrum der vorlesung widerstehen
philosophisch interessant sind stalder
erwehren zum beispiel nicht ethische
probleme die mit der digitalität
einhergehend auch gar nicht und
logischen fragestellung die nicht um die
frage nach der bedeutung virtueller
realität dreht diese ganze team lässt
schneider aus als seine kultur
wissenschaftlichen perspektive ist da
sicherlich berechtigt aber hier finde
ich gibt es einen sehr guten
anknüpfungspunkt diese frage weiter zu
thematisieren und noch weiter zu
vertiefen
jetzt möchte ich auf digitalität und
medialität ein den wir können nicht
kompetent von digitalität und
digitalisierung sprechen wenn wir uns
nicht zuvor gedanken gemacht haben über
dasjenige was einem medium ist
insbesondere das was das so genannte
neue medium sein soll
möchte ich hier aufmarsch region
eingehen ein ganz bedeutender
kanadischer kulturwissenschafter der die
sogenannte toronto school gegründet hat
und schule aus den 60ern 70ern da war
der sehr zentrale hat nach wie vor sehr
viele schüler die sich an auf ihn
beziehen und er hat ein buch geschrieben
guttenberg galaxy da möchte ich ein
zitat vorlesen typografie also die
schrift und der typ der buchdruck ist
nicht ist eine art technology part ist
in zerf anmerkte resources table leica
tv radio and like any state shapes not
only privat
sensations der kanal internet
interdependence als es handelt sich hier
um eine gewisse eine gewisse ressourcen
also es ist mir nicht nur ein
technologischer fortschritt durch gibt
den buchdruck sondern es findet hier
etwas materials stadt ja also eine
gewisse kultur geht damit einhergehendes
dann sogar die gutenberg galaxis spricht
von einer galaxie die durch die bucht
drucktechnologie hervorgebracht das
heißt wir dürfen
techniken transformative techniken nicht
nur technologisch verstehen sondern wir
müssen sie um adäquat gerecht zu werden
müssen wir schauen wie die ganzen
verschiedenen implikationen diese kultur
hat was ihn einhergeht und er ist wieder
der beliebte shape also der form
entscheiden
logi sind transformer t medien sind
transformative und verlieren dadurch
indem sie transformieren würden ihren
technologischen und ihren medialen
charakter medium als danach der
wortbedeutung
vermittlungsleistung oder auch prozent
leistung ein medium hat eigentlich eher
instrumentellen zweck ist soeben eine
information oder eine bedeutung
vermitteln sondern sender dann zu
empfänger von brot ist der bote der
vermittelt und dieses zitat legt nahe
dass wir medium nicht nur als ein
instrument verstehen dürfen als eine
vermittlungsinstanz sind dass wir das
medium gewissermaßen als eigene realität
ernst nehmen müssen jenseits von bloßen
instrumentellen verständnis es gibt noch
ein weiteres buch und da setzt sich
jetzt anderen der letzten vorlesung das
heißt understanding media extensions auf
mehr also die erweiterung extension die
ausdehnungen des menschen und das kommt
den neueren medien begriff wie ich finde
schon viel näher also medien sind nicht
nur vermittlungs instrumente sondern sie
sind erweiterungs instrumente oder noch
besser erweiterungen des menschen er hat
hier so ein paar sachen gebracht hier
sehen wir ganz verschiedene medien wenn
man nur ein paar ist es die elektrizität
wir hatten darauf schon zugenommen zu
beginnen das hier ist noch eine
schallplatte also
medienmusik medien wir haben wir
antennen
hamann knoten oder währungen film
schilder sind medien bücher natürlich
das führt zurück auf die guttenberg
alexy telefon heute wer hier vielleicht
ein handy ich bringe aber nachher noch
ein neues album cover wo dann ganz
analog dazu ein handy zu sehen und auch
mikrofon und radio das sind alles medien
und das sind nicht irgendwelche
hilfsmittel sondern sind erweiterungen
des menschen jetzt sagt ein lesebuch
folgen ist weder ist eine medium der
shakes and control ist dass kay
information association
bekannt auf users of saatchi ja er ist
der ssd ja in effekten in shaping the
form of human association
es geht also hier wieder um die form die
form die diese medien haben und mich nur
den inhalt den sie transportieren das
wäre wieder nur eine reduktionistischen
rein instrumentelle auffassung des
mediums noch ein zitat in der culture
like aus langer kasten splitting und die
weide aussehens elsa means of control
jedes sometimes anbieter verschickt
ihrem ipad in operationalen praktiker
die um ist message
berichtete personal social konsequenz
ist auf penny medium gibt es oft
extensions auf aus herbst ressort von uk
des interviews interface bei extension
aufs herz op rängen new technology jetzt
der entscheidende satz für den auch mit
blumen bedeuten und berühmt geworden ist
dieser hier medien ist eine message das
medium ist die botschaft an das medium
übermittelt nicht nur die botschaft sind
das medium hat an sich schon eine
bedeutung nicht nur eine vermittlungs
eine bedeutungs vermittlungs bedeutung
sind als solches schon eine bedeutung
man könnte das auch die performative
dimension des mediums nennen interessant
ist hier auch dass ich hier darauf zu
sprechen kommt dass es hier ein neues
cale als ein neues karla neuen maßstab
gibt den die neuen techniken ins spiel
bringen die neuen techniken die neuen
medien werden nicht mehr gemessen an
vorhergehenden maßstäben sondern durch
ihre einführung verändern sie auch die
bisherigen maßstäbe an denen sie
gemessen werden können also eine ganz
interessante wechselwirkung zwischen
technologischer innovation des mediums
und dem maßstab der bewertung der durch
das erscheinen der medien auch
rationiert wird ja also hier die neuen
technologien sind mehr als nur
hilfsmittel sie haben eine performative
so könnte man ständig nennt bedeutung
man kann es natürlich noch viel weiter
gehen und fragen hat das medium nicht
nur eine performative kulturelle
bedeutung vielleicht sondern auch eine
unter logische bedeutung oder eine
ethische bedeutung und diesen fragen
wollen wir uns in dieser vorlesung vor
allem wie das habe ich hier noch einen
weiteren philosophen der neuen medien
der den begriff der info sphäre gekriegt
hat und dieses buch heißt vierte
revolution
hier ist natürlich an gespielt auf auch
die gutenberg galaxis us den buchdruck
und
denen anknüpfen sagt luciano florida
gibt es die vierte revolution das ist
das aufkommen der neuen medien möchte
ich auch noch mal zu tag vorlesen die
neuen medien sind zur flori die umwelt
gestaltende anthropologischen soziale
und interpret aktive kräfte geworden sie
schaffen und prägen unsere geistige und
materielle wirklichkeit verändern unser
selbstverständnis
modifizieren die wir miteinander in
beziehung treten und uns auf uns selbst
beziehen und sie bringen unsere welt
scheidung auf einen neuen besseren stand
und das alles tun sie eben so tief
gefallen wie umfassend und unabhängig
die frage wie ist diese weltdeutung zu
verstehen die dadurch verändert wird wie
ist diese modifikation zu verstehen wie
ist die matte die die prägung zu
verstehen die diese neuen medien
besitzen ist das nur kulturell zu
verstehen oder gibt's hier nicht auch
ethische gewaltige ethische probleme die
damit einhergehen das ist jetzt die
frage die sich speziell
blick auf die neuen medien stellten den
weg fuhren einige hatte aber gemeinhin
gilt ja der computer als neues medium
und vielleicht auch das internet wobei
ich der meinung bin und da diese these
werde ich im folgenden noch genauer
verteidigen dass das internet gar nicht
adäquat als medium oder als neues medium
zu verstehen ist das wäre viel zu
oberflächlich und jetzt gibt es hier
eine philosophie der neuen medien die
wir behandeln müssen das heißt wir
können uns fragen warum sollten wir uns
philosophisch der digitalisierung
befassen das habe ich schon vorweg
gesagt sie betrifft uns alle
und findet specht hat dieses zitat
einmal geschrieben in seinem buch die 50
wichtigsten dinge der digitalisierung
das kann ich sehr empfehlen der
fortschritt der digitalisierung wird uns
zeitnah mit der wohl größten
zivilisatorischen herausforderungen
konzentrieren die es je zu bewältigen
gab es kann man sich fragen kann man
auch so reden über die elektrifizierung
also könnte man sagen der fortschritte
elektrifizierung wird uns zeitnah mit
der wohl größten zivilisatorischen
herausforderung konfrontieren diese
bewältigt gab anders gefragt gibt es
hier eine analogie zur elektrifizierung
oder ist es bei der digitalen technik
bei dem neuen medium nicht doch noch was
anderes ein altes medium wäre zum
beispiel eine können birne das ist auch
ein medium nach mit lohn ist das analog
zu verstehen zum computer oder zum
internet oder gibt es nämlich doch mit
different ich würde sagen wir dürfen es
nicht analog zu stehen ist findet hier
eine qualitative änderung statt das
müssen wir aber natürlich noch genauer
belegen genaue zahlen jetzt hole ich
jetzt aber die neuen medien stärker
philosophischen blick nehmen möchte
möchte ich auf die kritik der neuen
medien eingehen die nämlich auch in der
letzten zeit sehr häufig sich entwickelt
hat hier darf ich zunächst wenn manfred
spitzer der ein buch geschrieben hat mit
dem titel digitale demenz wie wir uns
und unsere kinder um den verstand
bringen ein weiteres buch hat den titel
selber krank wie das digitalisierte
leben unsere gesundheit reagiert und zum
schluss noch ein weiteres buch die
smartphone epidemie gefahren für
gesundheit bildung
gesellschaft hier kommt jetzt dieses
smartphone wieder ins spiel hier haben
wir
computerbildschirme konsolen tastaturen
usw das sind alles assoziation die wir
mit den neuen medien verbinden allein
auch die bildgebung ist immer
entscheidend wenn es um die darstellung
der neuen medien geht ich vertrete die
these dass es sich hierbei nicht um die
reduktion handelt die neuen medien sind
nicht nur bildschirme zählt nicht nur
spielekonsolen sind nicht nur handys
dass ich halt viel zu kurz auf
spitze bin ich in der letzten vorlesung
schon kritisch eingegangen ich finde
dass seine bücher werden dem phänomen
der digitalität keiner weise gerecht
obwohl man natürlich immer kritik
kritisch begleiten muss die
technologische entwicklung diese kritik
die spitze hier übt bezieht sich nur auf
das technische phänomen der
digitalisierung nicht auf das
philosophisch kulturelles phänomen der
digitalität warum später begreift das
internet potenziell als einen sucht raum
als ein suchtmittel den wir uns nicht
entziehen können das ist eine
pathologisierung der sicht auf die
digitalität die er nicht gerechnet das
internet so meine these begleitet uns
alltäglich ohne dass es zur sucht wird
sicherlich kann man jetzt sich jetzt
fragen können wir überhaupt noch ohne
internet leben diese frage halte ich
aber für falsch gestellt es geht nicht
darum ob wir ohne das internet überhaupt
noch leben können individuell anders mit
einem schuh trust das internet ist schon
zu einer infrastruktur geworden wie es
die elektrizität
seit einiger zeit schon ist ich bin mir
ziemlich sicher müsste noch genauere
zitate finden das vor 200 jahren
malerinnen und maler auf tragen die
sagten wir müssen uns vor der
elektrifizierung schützen das ist nicht
gut ja die elektrizität die trinkt immer
mehr in unseren alltag zurück zu den
wurzeln zurück zur natur heute kommen
wir überhaupt nicht mehr aus ohne
elektrizität und sie ist nicht so
schlimm natürlich können wir auch
schlimm ist damit machen aber das können
wir mit allen dingen das können wir auch
mit einem holzscheit oder mit steinen
und so weiter und genau so ist es jetzt
auch mit der digitalisierung auch die
ist einfach ein teil unserer lebenswelt
geworden es gibt kein zurück mehr und
das ist auch nicht schlimm die frage ist
nur wie gehen wir damit sinnvoll um und
wir begreifen müssen wenn sie teil
unserer lebenswelt geworden ist
unabhängig jetzt in meinen augen von
bloss psychiatrisch psychologischen
bedenken eben der sucht wie es spitze
tun das wird dem phänomen nicht gerecht
das möchte ich noch auf ein ganz neues
buch eingehen dass es ganz neu
herausgekommen von peter schmidt mit dem
titel post digitalmedien kritik im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert wir wieder
ein bezeichnendes bild was darauf zu
sehen
personen die auf das smartphone blicken
und dann irgendwann einen abhang
hinunter fallen hier wird suggeriert
dass wir alle irgendwie verbunden oder
unsere perspektive ja nach unten richten
also auch letztendlich ein rückschritt
machen durch die digitalisierung hier
muss ich dazu folgendes sagen dieser
blick ins handy ist so neu nicht es ist
zwar ein blick der mit medien zu tun hat
aber wenn sie mal binnen das sehen aus
den fünfziger 40er 20er jahren des 20
jahrhunderts die die menschen zum
beispiel in öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln
ihre zeitungen schauen dann hat sich da
eigentlich gar nicht wieder angehen
der unterschied ist das natürlich mit
diesen smart objects viel mehr möglich
ist und dass viel mehr verbindung und
dynamik enthalten
es geht jetzt hier ihm um einen
medienkritik im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert post digital was auch immer
damit jetzt gemeint ist das müssen wir
jetzt mal genauer anschauen und hierzu
möchte ich jetzt wieder auch ein paar
zitate aus diesem eigentlich
lesenswerten buch vorlesen zitat der
leiter des personals it takes der
stanford university stellte kürzlich
folgende prognose via twitter ins netz
zitat manager die post bietet average
1000 remy story als backbone chain to
your mobile von
kloster des blw simulators
okay es gibt eine post digitale bewegung
im jahr 2020
wir werden zu stehen das wir angekettet
sind dann unser das smartphone und dass
das ein ja ein ziemlich
schwaches verhalten ist ein lästiges
verhalten ein
problematisch zu halten dass demjenigen
des rauchens oder ist eine starke these
also werden wir alle zu rauchen weil wir
unseren blick unsere hände nicht mehr
lassen können von den smartphones ist es
wirklich die essenz der digitalisierung
und jetzt sagt dieser autor weiter in
diesem buch ziel dieses buches ist nicht
primär die verurteilung das monieren
eines negativen zustände ist vielmehr
geht es um den unverstellten blick das
genaue hinsehen und die nachvollziehbare
analyse die wirkungen der verlockenden
und gleichzeitig unheimlichen apparate
die wir zu tief in unser aller leben
integriert haben müssen rational
beurteilt werden es geht also nicht
primär darum etwas wie das rauchen oder
die smartphone sucht als schlecht
darzustellen dass hatte manfred spitzer
gemacht in diesen büchern die ich vorhin
vorgestellt hatte das wäre zu einfach
keine verteufelung der uns umgebenden
technik und keine ängstliche
schutzhaltung werden empfohlen sondern
eine fundierte kritische haltung denn
erst im zuge einer tiefen
auseinandersetzung lässt sich eine
selbstbewusste einschätzung vornehmen
die uns als menschen und als
gesellschaft weiter bringt ok sehr
sympathisch finde ich dass es eine nicht
zu reduktionistischen gdingen medien die
spitze keine verteufelung kein
ängstlicher schutzhaltung ist eine
fundierte kritischen haltung das wollen
wir jetzt mal schauen wie er jetzt diese
von der kritischen haltung auf die neuen
medien wird dazu möchte ich noch mal ein
zitat aus diesem buch vorlesen die
totale computerisierung entwickelt schon
seit jahren einen mahlstrom artige
genannt sie ist aber mittlerweile so
unnachgiebig wie ein schwarzes loch sie
zieht uns alle eine existenz weise
hinein für oder gegen die wir uns nicht
entscheiden können inhalte und die
wahrnehmung selbst wirbeln darin
unaufhaltbar in die neue dimension
die möglichkeiten sind darin unendlich
und zugleich negiert
denn hiervon gestand der satz restlichen
zeit von juristischen erwägungen zur
maschinellen vergessen aber auch
umkehren einmal hochgeladen bleibt ist
für immer bestehen in solchen
widersprüchen bündelt sich die gewalt
des umbaus kann man überhaupt noch
semantisch fassen was passiert viele
begriffe beweisen mittlerweile sogar auf
mir gegenteil gefühl wird zur logik
informationen zur desinformation
freiheit zu zwang technik zum mythos
individualität zu anpassung was hat das
zu bedeuten
ich finde jetzt erst mal von der wort
geben interessant dass er hier von einer
mal startet dynamisch das suggeriert
eine gefahr und von einem schwarzen loch
spricht das suggeriert nicht nur eine
gefahr sind auch ein völliges
unverständnis
dafür sagen unsere begriffe und genauso
argumentiert hier auch schmidt weiter
von zerren also er stellte
digitalisierung als eine dynamik als
eine macht da der wir uns gar nicht
erwehren können also es wird etwas
hetero- nomen wissensökonomie diese
entwicklung seine existenz weise ja das
könnte man auch die kultur der
digitalität nennen führt oder gegen die
wir uns nicht entscheiden können hier
würde ich ihnen völlig
zustimmen ebenso wie bei der
elektrifizierung können wir uns nicht
mehr dafür oder dagegen entscheiden wir
können zwar in den wald gehen ein
eremiten dasein erleben aber spätestens
dann wenn man mal irgendwie eine
krankheit bekommen sie mal froh wenn man
einen von elektrifizierten und wo sich
hinzufügen auch digitalisierten hospital
und da kommt so viel denke ich muss mir
dann schon viel heimat sagen die
möglichkeiten sind unendlich und
zugleich negiert hier steckte also an
dass ich eine völlig neue ordnung
entwickelt hier sei wieder an dieses
kehl an diesem maßstab verwiesen den
maschen blutspiegel katja durch die
transformation der neuen medien
verändern sich unsere macht es sehr wohl
da verändert sich sehr viel
respekt der von den vergessen die
maschinen vergessen dass auch umgekehrt
werden kann einmal hochgeladen bleibt
informationsträger bestehen was ist
damit gemeint hier gibt es den spruch
das internet vergisst nichts das ich
sehr interessant finde wenn wir daten
ins internet stellen sehen sie aus und
zwar kontrolle sie werden archiviert
durch bots durch verfahren die uns nicht
ersichtlich sind brauchen uns gar nicht
interessieren wie das technisch genau
bewerkstelligt wird es ist einfach so
dass das jetzt prinzipiell nichts
vergisst und das ist jetzt auch erstmal
völlig neutral zu beobachten was geht
damit einher wenn das internet ein
gedächtnis ein kulturelles gedächtnis
ist nicht nennen möchte was aber nichts
vergisst was alles wieder präsentieren
kann auch wenn es noch so lang vorbei
ist was folgt daraus für unsere
erinnerungskultur was folgt daraus für
unsere taten die wir begangen haben die
in der vergangenheit lagen und die jetzt
aber wieder plötzlich ans tageslicht
gezerrt hier gibt es verschiedene
beispiele von politikerinnen und
politiker die die eine jugendsünde
begangen haben die man dann plötzlich
wieder präsentiert bekommt und so auf
eine ganz andere weise als man sie
präsentiert bekäme wenn man eine zeugin
oder einen zeugen hören würden der diese
person damals gesehen hatte sondern das
internet präsentiert ist so als ob es
gerade eben passiert wäre gerade eben
geschehen wird das heißt den status der
information ist ein permanent präsent
ist hat ja kann man überhaupt noch
semantisch fassen was passiert das ist
die entscheidende frage die der autor
hier aufwirft und ich würde jetzt so
weit gehen zu sagen ja wir können ist
mir noch ja wir müssen es und zwar
philosophisch und eben auch in dieser
vorlesung wollen wir das tun ja noch ein
letztes zitat aus diesem sehr
interessanten buch zieht hat umfassende
implementierung der digitalen maschinen
erzeugt eine neue bedingung unseres
daseins sie wirft konkrete fragen auf
die an unserer selbstbild und an unsere
emotionen rühren wir fühlen wir uns
inmitten der totalen verrechnung unseres
lebens was bedeutet freiheit in
permanente digital und koexistenz
welchen wert hat heute nur ein bild
welchen wert hat muss
ist der mensch überhaupt noch das
subjekt der geschichte oder wohnt er der
technologischen entwicklung noch cool
substanziellen bei können wir beim
anwenden der massen programme noch von
indizien sprechen das sind alles sehr
berechtigte fragen nur das ist meine
kritik tagen sind diese fragen noch zu
sehr technologisch formuliert und nicht
auf der ebene der digitalität das sind
fragen die an eine technologische
entwicklung gestellt werden die als
fremd empfunden wird die noch nicht als
ein lebensweltliche faktor akzeptiert
und verstanden wurde das heißt diese
ganze entwicklung müssen hier irgendwie
als äußerlich erscheinen und wir werden
diesen entwicklung nicht gerechnet wir
sie als äußerliche finden sondern müssen
sie vielmehr als lebensweltlichen
integrierte bestandteile verstehen und
dann begriff nicht beschreiben aber auch
jenseits solcher etwas zucker steven
begriffen wie mal strömen oder schwarzen
lächeln das wird diesen alltäglichen
harmlosen finden größtenteils harmlosen
phänomen überhaupt nicht gerecht
deswegen möchte jetzt eine kritik der
kritik der neuen medien formulieren und
zunächst mal die these vertreten dass
digitalität mehr ist als nur die summe
der neuen medien digitalität ist mehr
als internet plus computer wird
spielekonsole plus smartphone plus und
so weiter und so fort das wird den film
in der digitalität nicht gerecht hier
kann man wieder bezug nehmen auf felix
stalder der von der kultur der
digitalität speckte die ganzen neuen
medien ergeben dass haben einen kontext
der diese medien in ihren einzelnen
bedeutung übersteigen oder auch von dir
und darauf müssen wir uns abwenden
damit hängt die zweite these zusammen
digitalität ist kein technologisches
fingerlängen das geld viel zu kurz die
these von schmidt dieses schwarze loch
das ist immer noch ein technologischer
blick der uns die technik als fremd
erscheinen ist wir sollten die technik
nichts als fremdes dastehen als etwas
integratives die these um die kultur der
digitalität zu verstehen müssen mit
ethischen etymologischen und unter
logischen grundlagen der digitalität
klären so viel steht fest jetzt komme
ich zu der entscheidenden these die aber
mit ihnen gemeinsam hier diskutieren
möchte in diesem semester der
schlüsselbegriffe eine philosophie der
digitalität ist der begriff der
virtuellen realität wir müssen also
nicht nur eins mehr realitäten oder
soziologische entwicklungen betrachten
sondern überhaupt uns mal gedanken
machen ob wir nicht einen neuen
realitäts begriff brauchen den wir
virtuelle realität nennen könnten und
der jetzt nicht zu verwechseln ist lose
simulation oder illusion wie man es sich
häufig vorstellen wie man so eine
wie aber brille auf den augen hat wo man
irgendwo in einem in anführungsstrichen
virtuellen raum ist das ist eine
simulation die täuschend echt ist aber
es ist in meinen augen nicht der fall
sinn von sexualität und dann um diesen
begriff drehte sich und dem müssen wir
genau bestimmen sonst zum eine these
können wir die ganzen phänomene die wir
durch die neuen medien hier präsentiert
bekommen nicht adäquat philosophie
verstehen so das war jetzt meine thesen
ich bedanke mich vielmals für die
aufmerksamkeit und wir gehen jetzt
weiter in die diskussion